Michel Marie est avec nous merci Michel
cette vidéo je l'ai vu j'ai un
soutenable
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé hier à
Bordeaux quand on voit ça je vous jure
c'est c'est on est on est on devient fou
je vous dis c'est 11-10 c'est ce monde
est fou alors
c'est exactement ça ces images sont
extrêmement parlantes déjà comment vont
la petite fille là et la grand-mère
alors physiquement ça va
elles sont psychologiquement totalement
détruites
parce qu'en réalité c'est une tentative
d'enlèvement il y a un vol et une
tentative d'enlèvement et on le voit
d'ailleurs très bien sur ces images il
arrache le tour de coude de la
grand-mère et en même temps il prend la
petite fille qui a 7 ans et il la
soulève il est il essaye de l'embarquer
et un moment il laisse tomber quelque
chose qui permet à la gamine de de faire
le tour il y a le chien qui aboie
iris et elle réussit à sauver mais et on
sait également qu'il y avait une voiture
relais c'est à dire qu'il y a une Clio
noire qui attendait cet individu
c'est à mon avis une tentative dans
alors c'est pas un quartier c'est un
quartier de Bordeaux tout à fait
tranquille alors je suis bourgeois
centre-ville de Bordeaux donc les
intentions d'individus qu'on m'a dit ça
semble être le vol et l'enlèvement
visiblement oui il est en repérage la
grand-mère ramenait la petite fille chez
son fils donc voilà et puis lui on le
voit mettre le pied il a repéré mettre
le pied dans la porte comme c'est
quelqu'un effectivement qui est très
défavorablement connu on voit
effectivement tentative d'agression et
puis volonté de sans doute de ces
questions alors la famille sachez-le se
dit indigné par la récupération
politique voilà et voilà ils sont
extrêmement choqués on pense fortement à
eux sans récupération aucune fait pas de
la politique ici bien sûr mais je veux
dire on se met tous à la place de cette
grand-mère et vous rendez compte c'est
bouleversant cette vidéo elle est
insoutenable alors le suspect est
interpellé de manière musclée et
compliquée paraît-il ouais alors la
chance dans cette affaire pour la police
c'est qu'il y a un visiophone qui nous
permet d'avoir ces images et ensuite
un témoin qui voit le suspect monté dans
une Clio noire et après c'est la vidéo
surveillance de la ville qui va faire le
reste du travail d'ailleurs les
policiers quand ils voient le cette
vidéo il reconnaisse instantanément un
individu qu'ils ont interpellé à de
nombreuses reprises
type qui a 15 condamnations à son casier
judiciaire il a 29 ans et depuis 2023
donc depuis quelques mois moins de 6
mois il y a trois dossiers et des
dossiers criminels où il s'agit de
violence de de port d'armes et
d'agression de policiers donc ce type
est extrêmement dangereux il est né en
France il nationalité française il a 29
ans
je viens de le dire il est lourdement
condamné et donc l'enquête est
relativement simple c'est par la vidéo
surveillance d'une caméra à l'autre il
suivent en réalité en presque en temps
réel à la fois le véhicule et le
personnage il est repéré
sur une sur une place et la place de
l'Europe et à partir de là les un
équipage de la de la BAC bon il y a
l'anti-criminalité va l'interpeller
l'interpellation se passe très mal il se
couche par terre refuse de monter dans
le véhicule de police
il a fallu le les policiers étaient
obligés de le Taser pour le rentrer deux
forces dans le véhicule de la police
alors on parle d'un profil c'est un
psychiatrique particulier qu'en est-il
alors la garde à vue a d'ailleurs été
levée parce qu'il était placé en garde à
vue en un premier temps après cette
interpellation musclée mais le
psychiatre qui est venu le visiter à
considérer que son état n'était pas
compatible avec la garde à vue et par
conséquent il a été pris en charge par
un hôpital psychiatrique il a un lourd
passé psychiatrique au-delà de son passé
judiciaire et il était en rupture de
traitement c'est qu'il prenait plus son
traitement et ce type n'a aucun frein et
assez absolument n'importe quoi et même
il est pas accessible à une sanction
pénale une fois de plus
voilà par contre il est en situation
parfaitement régulière puisqu'il est né
en France c'est les fameuses bombes
humaine psychiatriques dont on parle ici
depuis plusieurs casques est fou c'est
que cette personne qui a été
diagnostiquée schizophrène psychotique
troubles importants etc effectivement
risque d'échapper à toute sanction
pénale or il se balade impunément dans
les rues fait n'importe quoi il y a
tellement peu de psychiatres qu'il a
arrêté son suivi tout le monde s'en fout
et c'est des dangers mortels il y a
plein d'affaires récentes où on trouve
la même chose il faut d'urgence que ces
soins soient imposés que ces gens soient
suivis et pas en liberté c'est pas
possible autrement on peut pas continuer
comme ça c'est impossible on en parlait
pour l'agresseur d'Annecy bien sûr on
avait exactement la même discussion et
les gens et les gens le voient
le métro vraiment ce genre de profil
mais vraiment le même type avec la
chaussure qui qui braque qui brandit
comme ça en train de baver des mecs qui
crachent sur des femmes et tout ça c'est
moi je l'ai vu de mes propres yeux dans
le métro une femme se faire cracher
dessus par un fou qui devrait être
soigné qui ne devrait pas être dans le
métro et il est dans le métro est-ce que
est-ce que c'est normal et c'est les
gens le voient régulièrement vraiment tu
as raison je vous assure hein alors
est-ce qu'il pourrait échapper est-ce
qu'il pourrait échapper à la justice
alors si il est reconnu en terme
d'abolition de son discernement il y a
deux
nuances pour les psychiatres c'est
l'altération et l'abolition du
discernement altération c'est-à-dire une
réduction de peine abolition il y a pas
de procès
donc
il s'appelle Brahima B c'est un homme de
29 ans bordelais de nationalité
française et comme vous l'avez dit des
antécédents 15 antécédents judiciaires
conduites sans permis vol violence il
indique être suivi sur le plan
psychiatrique et être en rupture de
traitement il serait aussi son domicile
fixe
ils sont ils sont pas bêtes ils ont fait
une enquête parce qu'il me paraît il va
me paraît vraiment bizarre on dirait un
marginal on dirait un mec qui est foutu
qui a plus rien dans la vie il y va pour
enlever une petite gamine apparemment
parce qu'il c'est pour ça c'est très
maladroit il hésite à vendre rentrer
après une fois que c'est par terre je
fais mon enquête à deux balles mais les
gars de la Clio c'est qui c'est qui ces
gens là c'est qui c'était qui le mec
dans la Clio il faut peut-être aller
voir un peu plus loin parce que si on
l'aurait payé pour faire ça que ça
m'aurait pas étonné tellement c'est un
bras cassé c'est tout à fait possible
la drogue ou boire de l'alcool
pédophilie j'en sais rien mais tout est
possible mais pour l'instant en tout cas
ma connaissance individu qui était dans
la Clio n'a pas été interpellé et
d'ailleurs quand le suspect lui a été
placé en garde à vue avant que le
psychiatre ne le déclare
incapable d'être en garde à vue il n'a
rien dit et surtout il niait
on le voit on le reconnaît bien et il a
beau
place il était pas caché sur une place
en attendant qu'on vient de l'attraper
c'est quand même un peu c'est gros quand
même hein pour lesquelles il a été jugé
à chaque fois il a été donc coupable il
a été ça je sais pas le détail mais en
général quand on parle de condamnation
il a été quand on parle de condamnation
c'est qu'il a il a eu une peine
donc
le petit truc sur lequel je m'interroge
quand même c'est qu'il y avait quand
même une voiture qui l'attendait c'est
organisé c'est organisé c'est ce que je
me dis excusez-moi moi manque de
discernement là dessus il y avait une
voiture qui l'attendait c'était pas un
mec qui passait dans la rue
non mais vous avez raison il faut le
dire clairement aujourd'hui il y a des
gens lui je sais pas dans quel état il
était en plus il dit qu'on a la nation
pour stupéfiant etc bon lui c'est
quelqu'un qui a un habitué il a 15
condamnations 20 mentions au traitement
des antécédents judiciaires c'est un
habitué de la filière police justice des
interpellations est-ce que voilà il est
dehors ça c'est scandaleux est-ce qu'il
ne sait pas entre guillemets jouer avec
les psychiatres est-ce qu'il va pas
tomber sur un avocat qui va dire
appuyant là-dessus pour qu'il abolition
ou altération du discernement il y a
plein d'avocats qui jouent là-dessus en
ce moment parce que c'est une faille de
notre système judiciaire il rentre
là-dedans et du coup ils envoient les
gens en hôpitaux psychiatrique plutôt
qu'en prison et ça ça ne va pas il faut
vraiment se pencher là dessus
aujourd'hui on se raconte
dans les jours voir semaine qui suivent
il y aura une contre-expertise
psychiatrique avec un autre expert le le
voit et ce qu'il était sous-produit
stupéfiant c'est probable ça ressemble
un peu à craquer ça d'un mec qui prend
du crack CK
il y en a plein le problème c'est la
Clio et qui au-dessus de la Clio qui
m'intéresse parce que des mecs comme ça
à qui tu peux donner 500 balles c'est
d'accord
je te donne de la course